[音楽]
me
tod 2
[拍手]
はじめましてい
お化け屋敷プロデューサーの五味と申し
ます
僕はいつもですね夏になると
お化け屋敷のくれ網の中にいて
お客様の様子を見ています
ですからこのようなちょっと明るい道路に
来るといささか高をちょっとまぶしく感じ
てしまいます
お化け屋敷のその暗闇の中で一体僕がどの
ようなことをしているかと言うと
お客様の予想を見ながらちょっと今の
タイミングが悪かったなぁとかもっと
引き寄せて脅かさないとお客さんは喜んで
くれないっていうそういうような a 水
関わること
これももちろん考えているんですけれども
それと同時に
お客様がお化け屋敷の中でどんなことを
考えながら進んでいるのか
そういうお客さまの心の中のことっていう
ことに思いを巡らせてみていきます
今日は僕がその暗闇の中で考えている
なぜ人はお化け屋敷に次期作なるのか
このことについてちょっとお話したいと
思います
お化け足の暗闇の中で考えている怖いお話
を皆さんにするわけではないのでご安心
ください
ところで皆さんは
最強お化け屋敷に入ったことはありますか
私が初めて大人になって初めてお化け屋敷
に入ったのは
1992年
初めて私がお化け屋敷に携わるようになっ
たその年の初めのことでした
当時のお化け屋敷はどのように見られてい
たのかというと遊園地の片隅の方にあって
子供じめて古臭いそんなようなイメージ
でした
大人の人が
冷やかし半分に入っても真剣に楽しむ
そんなようなものではなかったんですね
ですから私もそのと同じような意識でその
お化け屋敷に入って行ってみました
祠があり
を今日の流れるを動画あり
そして墓石が並ぶ
そういう某地を歩いていきます
多少不気味ではあるんですけれどもそれ
ほど怖いなーっていうようなものではあり
ませんでしたところがある場面に来た時に
その私の意識っていうのがガラッと変わっ
たんですね
それはどういうところかというとお寺の
境内のようなところを歩いてきますすると
こちら側に古い井戸があります
その脇を通ろうとするとフォン移動なから
今後ゴンと音が聞こえますフット措置を見
たその瞬間にガンという大きな音とともに
白い雲が起きた音だけがワーッというふう
に襲いかかってきます
私はその様子を見て悲鳴を糸腰を抜かして
しまいました
その印象が非常に強烈だったのでお化け
屋敷を出てからもなぜ僕はあんな風に悲鳴
をあげてしまったんだろうというふうに
思っていましたっていうのもお化け屋敷は
子供じみて古臭いそんなようなものを持っ
てましたからまさか自分がそのお化け屋敷
の中で姫を上げるなんてことは想像もして
なかったんですねですからそれはどういう
ことなんだろうと思ってもう1回お化けし
が入っていましたそれと同じように井戸が
あってその移動の中から覚え県ワット
飛び出してくると同じように私は悲鳴を
上げて腰を抜かしてしまいますもう1回
入ってもそれは同じことですやっぱり僕は
腰を抜かしてしまいます
なんでだろーなんでだろーと思って時に
そうか
あれは
お化けに風した人間が襲ってくるから怖い
んだ
僕は一つのアイデアを
ありましたそれが
大人のためのお化け屋敷というアイディア
です
お化けに風した人間がくれ雨の中に何人も
いてそれが次から次へと襲ってきたら大人
でも悲鳴を上げるようなそんなおば木脚が
作れるんじゃないかそう思って作ったわけ
屋敷がこちらです
1998年に初めて作った麿赤兒のパナマ
会館これが私が初めて作ったお化け屋敷
です
の当時から私はお化け屋敷の中にいて
あるいは出口にいてお客様の様子を見てい
ます
するとある奇妙なことに気付くようになり
ましたねお化け屋敷から出口から出る出て
くるお客様が悲鳴をあげてると同時にその
後に大きな笑い声をあげてるんです
それはお化け屋敷の中でも同じです脅かさ
れて姫や首その次の瞬間に大きな笑い声が
起こっているんです
なんで笑い声が起こるんだろう
そもそも強いところじゃないか
そして僕はそれがきっと
自分が作ってるそのお化け屋敷の演出って
いうものがまだまだ強くなくて
と強く
怖いお化け屋敷を作らないとこれは成功し
ていると言える言えないんじゃないか
そんな風に思うようになりましただから
もっと怖いお化け屋敷もっと怖いお化け
屋敷
出てくるお客様が泣き叫んでへたり込み
そして家に帰ってもトイレに行けなくなる
ようなそんなお化け屋敷を作らないといけ
ないんじゃないかそんなことを2年も3年
も思い続けていました
blogger
ある時ふと思ったんですね
お化け屋敷は確かに怖いところです
けれども
強いだけのところにこんなのお客様も
いらっしゃるだろうか
もしかしたらお化け屋敷っては強いだけの
ところではない
それはもしかしたら楽しいっていうところ
ではないだろうか
これは
私にとって目からウロコが落ちるような
そんな大きな発見でした
お化け屋敷っていうのは
怖いっていう情動を使いながら楽しいと
言うかイラクを得る
そういう場所なんですね
でも
また僕は考えます
でもなぜ怖いっていうものが楽しいという
ことに変わっていくんでしょう
強いと楽しいなって歩いまったく正反対の
ものですよね
なぜこれがこんなふうに変わることが
起こるんだそれをは他クラブの中でずっと
考えていました
そしていくつかの心理的なメーカーね数
みたいなものがあるのではないかという
ふうに思うようになります
その一つは例えば
緊張は彼を押す
そしてもうひとつは本当んが整理される
そして主観が客観に変わる
またごっこ遊びをしてい
こういういくつかのメカニズムによって
強いということが楽しいということに
変わっていくんじゃないかなっていうふう
に思います今日はこのうちのこの後コア
遊びということに焦点を当ててお話をし
たいと思います
皆さんは子どもの時にごっこ遊びしたこと
ありますよね
私はあるときに小さい子供女の子が
お父さん糖尿こうしている様子を見かけ
ました
お父さんがおばけだぞーって言って
襲いかかってくると女の子はキャーと悲鳴
と笑い声を上げて逃げていきます
繰り返していくとこの記名とはライムが
どんどんどんどん大きくなっていきます
女の子は
お父さんていう現実
を見ていますけれども同時におとうさんが
演じているオバケというフィクションも見
ています
この女の子にはお姉ちゃんがあります
このお姉ちゃんはお父さんの様子を見
ながら何をバカなこと言ってんのっていう
風にちょっと冷めた目で見ています
なんかよくある光景ですよね
お姉さんは
応答さという現実を見ているんですけれど
も多く理由というフィクションは見てい
ないんです
お父さんがお化けに見えるためには
ソース効力という物は必要になってきます
ね
で
この想像力っていうものを働かせるため
そのためには
お父さんの演技っていうだけではパリない
んです
それだけではお父さんはお化けに見えない
その他にないものを何度になっているかと
言うとビル側が大臣暴行的な想像力を働か
せてお父さんをそう
いうそのオバケだっていうふうに見ている
んです
で行われていることっていうのは
お父さんをお化けに見立てるそういう積極
性が働いているんですね
女の子は
積極的なその想像力を働かせることによっ
てお父さんをお化けっていうものに見立て
ているんです
皆さんは目せぼの村っていうものをご存知
でしょうか
聞いたことがあるけれど見たことがないと
いう方がほとんどだと思います
いつもの親はエビ女だとか
匹を吹く人だとかあるいは怪しげな何か
こう動物のミイラんって言うなものを見せ
たりそのようなさまざまな演目によって
構成されています
デカせてそのにせぼの上では
世紀の大マジックというものが披露されて
いました
見たこともないような世紀の大マジックで
すっていうふうに煽って煽ってお客様の
期待をどんどん上げていきます
そこで披露されるものは
何度も見たこともあるような使い古された
もうネタも知っているようなそんな
マジックです
塾を見て拍手をする人なんていないだろう
っていうふうに皆さん思うと思います
私も同じです
ところが
お化け屋敷でば3鯖も家では
いうマジックに拍手どころか買う性さえも
起こってくるんです
なぜそんなことが起こるのでしょう
スーッとそのことが不思議でしたでも
見世物小屋に行ってみるとその理由って
いうのがよくわかります
お客さんはマジプって言う
何かこう
おかしな現象が起こる
この現象を見に行っているわけではないん
ですね
お客さんは
見たこともあるようなマジックっいうもの
を
なんてくださ
世紀の大マジックっていうふうに見立てて
いるんです
そこで行われていることっていうのは症で
はないです
ごっこ遊びなんですよね
大切なことは
兵器のだ今実父であるっていうことでは
なく見ているお客さんがそのそのマジック
を正規のだ今10分
ことが大事なんです
あっての
鬼ごっこの話ちょっと戻しましょうか
お父さんがおばけだそうっていう風に言っ
たときにそれは自分の方に跳ね返ってき
ます
お父さんがおばけになった瞬間ねー
それを見ている自分は
そこから逃げる人になっていなければいけ
ないですなぜならばそうでなければオバケ
の脅威っていうものは成立しなくなって
しまうからです
お父さんがおばけになった瞬間その相手は
お化けをを馬券にから逃げる人間っていう
ものを演じているんです
このがさっきのその店ものはでも言えます
見たこともないような
兵器の大魔神っていうものに
見立てたその習慣にそれを見ているその
観客はそうもに歓声を上げている少し頭の
おかしな人間というものを演じているん
です
それが
ごっこ遊びが楽しさなんですね
さてお化け屋敷です
お化け屋敷ではこの演技というところに
ポイントがあります
は毛足は自分の身体が脅威にさらされると
いう非常に高
を切羽詰まった生々しい体験を伴っていき
ます
ですから直接それを自分でなんとか
受け入れない良いちょっと避けようって
いう風な4いうような働きが行われていき
ます
時にどういう方法をとるか
その一つが
お化け屋敷っていうものを5個遊びの休館
に置き換えてしまうということを行えます
どういうことかもどういう事をするかと
いうとまず
まず
を理由に怯える人間っていう存在を作り
ます
でその存在を自分で演じる
しながらお化け屋敷の中を通っていくん
ですね
すると目の前で起こっていることはすべて
フィクションに置き換えられてしまいます
どんな教委が襲ってこようと思うそれはお
化けでを演じている自分が受けていること
なので実際の自分に実が様を呼ぶことは
ない
その脅威がどれだけ大きくてもそれが
遊びのことになっていってしまうっていう
そういうような転換が行われているんです
ね
お化け屋敷が楽しくなるそのメカニズムは
実はここに隠されているんです
お化け屋敷がボッコ遊びの空間に変わる
ことによって恐怖が楽しいっていうものに
変わっていきます
私がなぜお化け屋敷は
に人が行きたくなるのか
このことの理由の一つそれはここにあり
ます
ところで
ラッキーお姉ちゃんが何お父さんバカな
ことをしてるのって
なことを言った言いましたよね
でもなにバカなことを言ってるのっていう
よりも
キャーって言って逃げた方が楽しいという
ふうには思わないでしょうか
お父さんがおばけだぞーって言ったときに
そこから逃げる女の子の心の中には何か
こう遊びたいっていうかすかな石のような
ものを
それが芽生えてるんじゃないかなっていう
ふうに思います
もう少し丁寧な言い方をすればそれは1と
いうような主体性を伴うものではなく
むしろ体のうから方からわき上がってくる
かすかな衝動っていう方が正しいのかも
しれません
のパスかな衝動っていうのは
あそぼころって言っ
呼んでもいいかもしれません
世界っていうものは
私たちがコーデあるっていう風にとらえて
いるからそこにあるわけですね
つまり正解はそこにあるんどで長く私たち
はそう捉えているんです
ある意味世界があるのではなく私たちが
世界を奏しているんですね
ですからあるのではなくてする
などではなくてするというところに遊び心
が加わった時にいっぺん退屈に見えるこの
世界っていうのはその遊び心によって輝く
もに塗り替えられているのではない
でしょうか
ですからもしかしたら
遊び心というのは私たちに与えられた魔法
の杖なのかもしれないです
ですから皆さんはもしオバケだぞーって
言われたらすかさず
ターっていう風に見えるようにしましょう
そうすると皆さんの人生は必ず明るく
照らされることになっていくと思います
さていよいよ本題です私がぺ雨の中で考え
て怖いお話を皆さんにしなければいけない
と思っているんですが残念ながら時間に
なってしまいました
今日の話はここまでです
どうか皆さん
遊び心を忘れないようにありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]